The sauce, Kevin here with historical proof that Isaac Newton was wrong.
At least once in his storied career,
he seems to have been right about gravity and
calculus and physics,
8,000 other things that redefined how humans thought about math and science.
But heres what Newton couldn't quite handle
dice.
Some of the are going to think I'm wrong and others we'll agree
that Newton was wrong, but ye will think that it, it doesn't even matter.
This let's start by talking about peeps real quick.
This video is sponsored by Ray con wireless earbuds that won't break the old
bank. They look nice. Fitwell sound great.
And the everyday [inaudible] feature the following stats, six hours of playtime,
seamless, Bluetooth pairing, more bass,
more efficient design and new colors.
Also the compact carrying case charges,
your earbuds four times on a single charge re con earbuds start at about
half the price of other premium wireless earbuds brands and sound just as
good. So to get yours, go to buy Ray con.com/vsauce two,
to get 15% off your order and thanks to Ray con for supporting
Vsauce tube. Okay.
Samuel peeps gained fame as England's chief secretary to the Admiralty and
eventually became the sixth president of the Royal society of London,
the oldest national scientific institution in the world,
but now he's most famous for his letters and meticulous diaries
in 1693,
peep sent a dice gambling problem to one of the most brilliant mathematical
minds alive, sir, Isaac Newton.
It's the only time Newton's seems to have worked on profitability.
And even though he was mostly right,
he was still wrong.
Here's how peeps made a wager with a man named John Smith over which of the
following scenarios was the most likely to occur,
or if they were all equal a has six dice in a box with
which she is to fling a six B has in another box,
12 dice with which he is to flame two sixes C has
an another box 18 dice with which he is to flank three
sixes queue,
whether B and C have not as easy a task as a,
at even luck peeps problem.
Isn't hard to figure out until it is on the surface.
Is it easier to get one six in six dice or
three sixes in 18 dice?
Or is there no difference at all?
In terms of probability peeps posited see with three
sixes in 18 dice was the most probable more
dice, better odds. Hey,
what are we even doing with ye dice?
We're using standard six sided dice with each side equally likely as an
outcome. No funny business here.
The odds of getting a six on each individual role are a simple
one in six. Now we just need to fling them.
Wait, we've got a language problem.
Is the bet here to find out whether we're flinging a six or
does that imply at least one six,
because exactly one six and at least one six are
two different things. And that would apply to B and C two.
It's a critical point in figuring out exactly what our odds are and whether
there's any difference as the exchange letters,
Newman interpreted peeps problem as being satisfied with at least the
minimum number of sixes and well peeps predicted that the best
shot to win was rolling.
At least three sixes and a fling of 18 dice Newton
proved it was the opposite.
A is most likely B is the next most likely.
And in ye third case,
ye value will be found still less.
And I know that people don't believe this.
There are articles written to this day 300 years later,
claiming that the probability does not change when he ed
dice,
after all every dye has that one in six chance of coming up
six kind of set of six dice is really just six individual
dice, 12 and 18. That's just two and three sets of six,
but they're wrong.
And I'll show you why it's time to prove this by flinging some
dice mathematically,
all the possible probabilities of an event need to add up to
one. So in a coin flip,
there's a 0.5 probability of heads and a 0.5 probability
of tails.
And the probability of one of those two outcomes occurring is 0.5 plus
0.5 equals one because one of those two things is certain
to happen. And it's the same with our dice game.
So to find the probability of something happening,
it's usually best to calculate the probability of that thing,
not happening, and then subtracting it from one,
those are the only two outcomes here it happens, or it doesn't.
So that calculation everything minus failure leaves us with the
probability of success.
The probability of rolling a six is P hold on. I gotta,
I gotta find my marker probability of finding my marker. 100%.
The probability of rolling a six is P so P equals one over
six. The probability of not rolling.
A six is one minus P.
So the probability of not rolling a six with six dice,
our a scenario is one minus P raised to the sixth power
plug in the one over six value for P and the probability of
rolling@leastonesixwithjustsixdiceequalspointsixsixfiveonedot.dot.
We do the same thing for B it's not any more sophisticated.
There are just more terms and a little extra steps since rolling.
Only one six in 12 dice is now considered a failure to,
so the probability of B equals one minus P raised to the 12th power
minus 12,
over one times P times one minus P to the 11th power
that simplifies to one minus one plus 11 P
times one minus P raised the 11th power.
And when we put in our one over six value, again,
the probability of succeeding in scenario beat is
0.6187.
It's about five percentage points,
less than the odds of winning with only six dice.
And that's actually about a 7% swing in outcomes.
And like Newton said, C is even worse.
Ye value will be found still less turned out to be 0.5,
nine, seven, three, but Newton didn't actually calculate the third scenario.
He had to calculate all of this math by hand,
not using the simple probability notation we just used.
And he actually made a really detailed series of tables that people
could use to do the calculations himself.
Newton's tables used first principles,
basic knowledge rather than complicated specialized knowledge.
So peeps could confirm the calculations like this and plug in his own
values. So for example,
the probability of at least one six and a toss of six dice is
obtained from column F by dividing row nine outcomes with at least
one six by row two, total outcomes for the dice throne.
It's simple, elegant genius. I,
and he can do it a lot more simply and crunch the numbers on a calculator or
run a simulation of say 100,000 trials of 18 dice
rolls and just a few seconds to confirm the results.
But if ye wants tables like peeps got
tables, Isaac Newton didn't have those computational tools.
And to be honest, he wasn't that familiar with probability.
No one in the 17th century was,
that's why he got the numbers, right?
And he got the reasoning wrong. In 2006,
Steven Stigler, a professor of statistics at the university of Chicago,
detailed a serious flaw in Newton's logic.
As the correspondence evolved,
Newton's assigned scenario a to a fictional man named Peter and scenario
B two James.
He explained that Peter only needed one six in his fling of
six dice while James needed a six in each flaying of six dice.
So it was easier for Peter to win same with the unnamed
player. See who's flinging 18 dice Newton completely
ignored the possibility of getting more than one six in each
fling.
And that's just a different problem than the one we're dealing
with here. If that seems like a minor detail,
it really isn't. Yeah, his explanation was wrong,
but his answer was right.
And that seems to be enough for most people,
almost no one talks about how his conclusion was
wrong. And that's, what's amazing about this problem to me.
Does it matter if he are wrong about why
you are right on number 23rd,
1693 in his third letter on peeps dice problem Newton's
explanation conflated that original language problem.
I pointed out whether we are hoping to get exactly a number of sixes or
at least a certain number. He was confused.
He knew the math and he nailed it despite probabilistic thinking,
not even really being a thing in his era,
but his reasoning couldn't quite catch up to the numbers.
That's okay. And for centuries,
we kind of let that go.
Part of it was that it took a long time to develop enough knowledge to know
why Newton's explanation wasn't exactly right.
Probability seems to have evolved from wanting a better understanding
of gambling and the numbers were accurate.
And part of it was that he's Isaac Newton,
no one's making a career. We are disputing the details of a man on humanities,
Mount Rushmore of math and science, except Stigler.
And I, I guess me,
but Newton peeps problems shows us how numbers can't just
exist on their own.
They work hand in hand without understanding of the problems
they're applied to.
And really Newton's solution has evidence that ARCOMs razor is right.
That the simplest method is probably the right one.
And the simpler sequence of events is probably going to work
more often.
We use that mindset to develop and improve everything from
manufacturing and assembly lines to coding software for
sustainability. We need it to progress.
The important thing is someone needs to get complicated
about getting simple,
to prevent seemingly simple things from getting suddenly
complicated,
which makes things simpler for us so that
we can move on to things that are more complicated.
And as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].